man muss nicht lange durch pekings
straßen fahren um zu sehen wie omikron
das leben verändert der wohnblock
wrapping liegen ist einer von mehr als
40 blogs sind der hauptstadt die ab
gerettet sind keiner kommt raus keiner
kommt rein alles muss angeliefert werden
mamming hat es noch gut er ist et
spezialist kann zu hause arbeiten
sobald ich internetanschluss habe billig
geschäftstüchtig aber das gilt für viele
nicht viele müssen ins büro zu ihrem
arbeitsplatz wenn ihr sie zu hause
einschließen verlieren sie ihren job
frau horn hat ein anderes problem denn
sie kommt nicht mehr in ihre wohnung ein
sie ruft ihre mitbewohnerin an die soll
ihr ein paar sachen bringen sie war
gerade arbeiten als die behörden ihre
siedlung dichtmachten
sie bringt mir meinen ausweis und eine
winterjacke vorbei ich habe keine
kleidung mehr
in robin li hat es gerade mal einen fall
gegeben im haus 29
die behörden haben angst vor einer
mikrowelle regeln deshalb gleich die
ganze siedlung ab frau horn wohnt jetzt
erstmal bei freunden sie weiß nicht wie
lange noch es ist schwer zu sagen wann
sie den locker und aufheben vielleicht
in zwei wochen fragen will sie
ich weiß nicht hängt davon ab ob alle
mitmachen
damit niemand auf die idee kommt nicht
mitzumachen gibt es herrn er bewacht
dieses haus es steht unter quarantäne
niemand darf raus oder rein seine
schicht dauert zwölf stunden essen wird
für ihn und die bewohner vorbeigebracht
halo findet die maßnahmen richtig denn
die omikron variante bedroht china
es gibt jetzt im ganzen land corona die
lage ist schlecht ich wollte ende april
nach hause fahren aber jetzt weiß ich
nicht ob das noch geht ich habe gehört
meinestadt.de an ist auch im lotter
präsident sieht keine alternative zu 0
kokot strategie denn bisher ist china im
vergleich zu anderen ländern sehr gut
durch die pandemie gekommen doch diese
strategie ist nur noch mit immer
schärferen kontrollen durchzuhalten
wenn es nur in einer region einen
ausbruch gibt der nicht schnell
eingedämmt wird dann droht sich das
ganze land zu infizieren china ist dafür
im moment nicht bereit
es ist ein wettlauf gegen die zeit denn
die omikron welle rollt durchs land wie
inseln die 17 millionen metropole
gleicht einer geisterstadt
die straßen menschenleer
eine woche lang befand sich die ganze
stadt im lockdown bei gerade mal einigen
hundert fällen
handyaufnahmen die chinas behörden nicht
schnell genug zensieren konnten zeigen
wie eingesperrt sich die menschen fühlen
mitten durch die wohnviertel zieht sich
eine mauer die bewohner sind verzweifelt
schreien
ich kann es nicht mehr aushalten
und beendet die charaktere
jenson ist das technologiezentrum
chinas firmen wie tencent und uwe kommen
von hier apple lässt seine iphones ihr
zusammen bauen wenn die behörden diese
stadt lahmlegen da nimmt chinas
wirtschaft schaden ja einmal muss man
sagen dass schön denn die einwohnerzahl
von nordrhein westfalen hat und
gleichzeitig das proto sozialprodukt von
südafrikas wenn denn ein problem hat
dann hat china ein problem die lage in
shenzen normalisiert sich langsam aber
dafür verschafft sie sich in shanghai
der anderen wirtschaftsmetropole des
landes teilweise ist die stadt im lotto
lange schlangen an den teststationen nur
mit einem negativen ergebnis können
viele zur arbeit gehen in den sozialen
medien finden sich dramatische szenen
diese frau fleht darum dass ihr kranker
mann den abgeriegelten wohnblock
verlassen darf kein krankenhaus will ihn
aufnehmen
bitte retten sie mein mann er hat krebs
im endstadium
bitte finden sie für uns ein arzt der
uns hilft
später schreibt sie ihr mann sei
gestorben
in hongkong wütete die omikron welle am
schlimmsten vor knapp zwei wochen
mussten sie särge ranschaffen und mobile
kühlcontainer für die vielen leichen
aufstellen seit mitte februar hat es
fast 6000 tote gegeben in hongkong haben
sie nun mobile krankenhäuser aus dem
boden gestampft um die vielen
infizierten zu behandeln bilder die ein
wo hahn vor zwei jahren erinnert lange
haben die offiziellen die
ansteckungsgefahr von omikron
unterschätzt
das virus verbreitet sich schnell die
maßnahmen sind verwirrend
zurück in die hauptstadt pekings führung
machen die vielen toten angst sie kennt
nur eine antwort lockdown
man mich fragt sich allerdings wie lange
sich die bürger pekings einsperren
lassen
die menschen so ein zug verchen geht
doch gegen bären freien willen
ehrlich gesagt glaube ich nicht dass
dieses ewig gutgehen kann
omikron droht außer kontrolle zu geraten
peking verschärft die maßnahmen weiter
helmut bleibt auf seinem posten bei wind
und wetter chinas führung weiß sie kann
sich auf ihn verlassen